*Gémissement de Natsu*
*La porte grince et la musique commence*
Bonjour les amis j'espère que vous allez bien.
Moi ça va
En vrai ça va pas je viens de me lever et quand je viens de me lever je suis toujours grincheux
Il y a quelques années j'avais fait une vidéo montrant le vrai visage de Jumbo
Et aujourd'hui on va faire pareil avec Natsu.
Attention Spoil ,même derrière la caméra il est très gentil
Mais ce qui est cool c'est que c'est un chien donc on va sortir de chez moi on va bouger ça va être rigolo
Ne tournez jamais après vous être levé,
C'est une très mauvaise idée
Premier truc à faire c'est de lui servir sa bouffe
*Bruit d'asmr d'ouverture de paquet*
Petites news ,il n'y a pas longtemps Natsu s'est blessé à la patte. Oh non!
Dans l'ascenseur les portes sont des portes accordéon,
Et en fait en s'ouvrant la porte est passée sur la patte de Natsu,
Donc ça lui a fait une mini plaie donc je dois lui filer des anti-inflammatoires
Sous forme liquide tout les matins pendant sept jours, un plaisiiiir. :')
L'avantage, c'est que j'ai l'impression d'être docteur House
*Musique générique Dr House*
Donnons-lui ce pourquoi il nous aime, mais en plus c'est faux.
Il ne m'aime pas que pour la bouffe, il m'aime aussi parce que je suis beau.
*petit clin d'oeil sexy de squeezie ;)*
Qui veut un pan-cake ?
*Natsu aboie*
Le vrai visage de Natsu ça commence
*Musique*
Bon comme je vous ai dit Natsu s'est blessé à la patte et en plus du truc que je dois m'être dans sa bouffe tous
les matins je dois lui désinfecter la plaie et mettre de la crème trois fois par jour pendant une semaine
*sourire malaisant*
On va faire ça bien
*Musique générique Dr House*
Bah oui c'est pas agréable.
*Bruit du Pchit Pchit*
C'est désinfecté
Il nous reste la crème mon grand
Je te la mets vite fait bien fait
*Musique générique Dr House*
C'est bieeeen, il a pas crié
Oooh
Vous vous rendez pas compte à quel point
Un Shiba quand ça crie c'est horrible, c'est un mix entre une porte qui grince et un avion qui passe
*Bruit HORRIBLE d'un Shiba qui crit *
Ensuite le but c'est de le divertir pendant quelques minutes normalement faut aller en balade
de manière à ce qu'il y pense pas et à ce qu'il ne se lèche pas pendant que la crème agit sur la petite plaie...
Natsu est vraiment content comme vous pouvez le voir il est ravi, ça lui fait très plaisir :)
*Petit rire*
Nous sommes prêts à bouger au parc et à voir Natsu s'éclater avec son copain! Natsu bisous!
Putain il est vraiment fâché normalement il peut pas résister quand je fais ça
Est ce qu'on est prêt à y aller? Ça veut dire oui!
*Musique*
Chers amis,
Vous allez voir un Natsu heureux dans très peu de temps, il commence déjà à s'exciter je galère
Il va jouer à l'infini avec son meilleur ami.
*Flûte*
Je suis avec Laïm
RPZ
le papa de Nako, ça faisait deux jours qu'on les avait pas sorti parce qu'il faisait très très froid et tout et c'est un peu
une secte en fait ceux qui ont des chiens
Laïm : C'est ça carrément!
Moi j'ai remarqué que c'est vraiment une secte que tout le monde se connaît maintenant les chiens ils se connaissent aussi
Laïm : Carrément
Squeezie :  c'est vraiment un délire euh que je ne soupçonnais pas
On va aller dans une autre partie du parc pour leurs mettre les harnais Go Pro on va voir ce
que c'est d'être un chien et de jouer avec son meilleur pote, Et voilà !
les go pro sont mis sur les Doge, Nako a la sienne et Natsu a la sienne, maintenant ils ont plus qu'à jouer
Go! Go! Natsu go!
Natsu il fait la gueule quand je lui mets il veut pas bouger, Natsu t'as décider de tuer ma vidéo c'est ça ?
Laïm : C'est ça qu'il veut faire
Ah ah aaaah! Les premiers pas! Oh ouiiiii! Alleeeeez!!!
En direct du dos de Natsu, vous qui chevauchez Natsu depuis le début de cette vidéo, il ne veut pas bouger tant que le harnais est là!
Je vais retirer le harnais et regardez bien ce qu'il se passe
Il est parti et voilà! Là il n'y a plus de problème ! Là les brindilles d'un coup elles l'excitent toutes!
Deux heures plus tard Natsu est extrêmement fatigué!
Nako lui pourrait enchaîner huit heures et demie mais papa doit aller travailler
Vous avez vu j'ai dis papa c'est pour vous indiquer mon niveau de gaga c'est assez puissant
Vous allez voir comment ça se passe quand je l'emmène au bureau.
- Laïm, nos chemins se séparent ici.
- Ciao Ciao !
Squeezie : - J'te fais des bisous.
Laïm : - Merci beaucoup.
bisous Nako! Bye byyye!
Il est où le bureau?
C'est à gauche !
Et c'est partiiiiiiii.
Ah tu veux de l'eau? Ok je te sert
*Chantonne*
*défonçage de caméra par papatte de Natsu*
Mais non qu'est ce que tu fait je voulais juste te filmer entrain de boire
Bois mon grand bois.
Je vous avoue, aujourd'hui j'ai rien à tourner,
J'ai pris de l'avance :3
Moi je suis un gars sérieux mais habituellement il se pose juste ici exactement comme il en train de faire. Dès que je me mets
Sur l'ordi, il est content on était pas venu depuis 2, 3 jour, il est content
C'est comme sa deuxième maison c'est trop drôle
Hein Natsu? Mon bébouuu!
regardez bien ce qui va se passer je vais aller me laver les mains
vous allez entendre Natsu crier à la mort c'est ça qui fait c'est terrible ça me brise le cœur il déteste être ici tout
seul parce qu'il n'y a pas de chat! Et généralement même quand je dors à l'appart dans ma chambre
les chats restent dans le salon avec lui mais ici non donc il pète un câble.
J'vais me laver les mains mon grand !
Reste !
C'est bien mon chien!
*Couinement de Natsu :'( *
*bruit de pas proche*
Alors alors je me lavais les mains je me lavais les mains, vous avez vu je pars exactement
4 minutes et on dirait que je suis parti deux jours! C'est le seul côté embêtant avec Natsu sinon tout le reste il est
formidable donc du coup c'est trop bizarre je fais une vidéo sur le vrai visage de natsu me regarder il est tout mignon tout le temps
vous savez ce que j'adore faire quand je vais au bureau pas pour tourner mais pour trouver des idées au juste rien faire
j'adore aller embêter Mcfly et Carlito
*rire de sitcom*
McFly: Putain mais c'est quoi cette serie mec ?!
Aujourd'hui je fais une vidéo sur Natsu du coup je vais au bureau , je montre comment il se comporte au bureau
McFly: Regarde comme il me kiff
McFly: Coucou Natsu bibou bisous bibou
Squeezie: Non McFly C'est pas..
Squeezie: Non ça c'est.. C'est pas Natsu c'est un..
Squeezie: C'est un Nounours
McFly: Aaah
Squeezie: Il est là, il est derrière toi le vrai
*rire de sitcom*
MacFly: D'accord!
Squezie: Il a pissé ?
Carlito : Chien de mer**
Squeezie: Mais Natsu tu fait quoi ?!
*McFly qui parle en arrière plan*
Squeezie: Put**n mais c'est quoi ça ?
Squeezie: Il tourne la tête c'est lui ! Il tourne la tête, non c'est bon, si c'est lui c'est lui.
Squeezie: Noooon
Squeezie: Non non mais si ça se trouve c'est une tache c'était déjà là depuis toujours
Carlito: Ouais Ouais
McFly: Non mais mec t'est horrible
Squeezie: Touche voir !
MacFly: *cri du coeur* Aaah c'est mouiller !
Squeezie: Putain Natsu il a pissé
Squeezie: Mais David (McFly) tu fais quoi ?
McFly: Hein ?!
*rire de sitcom*
*Carlito souler + rire de sitcom*
*OOOOOh venant aussi de Sitcom et McFly qui rage*
Carlito: Arrête t'es chiant!
Carlito: Descend, descend c'est vers ma cuisse droite
McFly: 'tension
McFly: BOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!
*sourire flippant*
Squeezie: Là je suis toujours entrain d'embêter McFly et Carlito
Squeezie: Et ils sont entrain de bosser sur leur prochaine musique
Squeezie: C'est les euh...
Squeezie: Les *censuré*
Carlito: Mais vraiment
McFly: Non mais le spoil
Carlito: Non mais vraiment tu peux pas, ça tu peux pas
*Rire qui fait mal aux oreilles*
Squeezie: Natsu a beaucoup trop joué
Squeezie: On est sur un dodo conséquent
Squeezie: Qui dure déjà depuis plus d'une heure
McFly: T'a pas un.....Oh putain l'autre il filme..
Squeezie: ça marche à chaque fois j'adore
Squeezie: Oh ! Tu as faillit marcher sur mon chien ! J'ai vu !
McFly: Mec tu fais un événement de rien du tout ! J'était vraiment autour de lui a faire attention !
Squeezie: Non tu allais lui marcher dessus je l'ai vue !
McFly: C'était sur la distance raisonnable...
Natsu: *Un objet non identifié vient interférer avec mon corps ! Quel est cette chose ?*
Natsu: Oui , vas y , caresse moi !
Squeezie: C'est tonton David il fait n'importe quoi avec toi !
Squeezie: Bon les mec je vous fait des bisous a bientôt
Carlito: Saluut !
McFly: A bientôt
Squeezie: Tu as fait un doigt?
McFly: Non mais t'es fou j'ai dit salut !
McFly: *Mytho*
Re bienvenue à la maison Chien
Il est maintenant temps de te brosser avant cette belle fin de journée
Alors le Shiba pour ceux qui ne savent pas a un poil auto-nettoyant c'est formidable
C'est a dire que comme ça il se roule dans la boue, quand ça va sécher, ça va tomber et tu seras en paix
Prenez une brosses avec des pics pas en métal au bout
Et il perd des poils de fou !
Tu perds des poils
Oh Put**n il y a un chat
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur le vrai visage de Natsu
J'espère que ça vous a plu vous savez maintenant ce que ça fait d'avoir un chien au quotidien
C'est ça tooooout les jours
J'ai la chance d'avoir un métier qui me permet de m'occuper de mon chien comme il se doit
Je peux l'emmener au taf avec moi je gère moi même les horaires et donc les horaires
ou je vais au parc avec Natsu, fin c'est trop bien
donc merci pour ça merci pour lui je le rappelle quand même si jamais un jour vous prenez un chien
n'oubliez pas que c'est pas un objet c'est un animal faut prendre en compte toutes ces contraintes et une fois qu'on les a acceptées on est
heureux comme tout
Il vient vraiment de m'abandonner?
vidéo par SQUEEZIE
sous-titre par serjoss
montage par Clément